they started selling coca-cola
door-to-door I sold gotten door-to-door
or so Saturday impulse Liberty magazine
Ladies Home Journal you name it you need
to figure out how to be the best you and
I have this great luxury I love my job I
tap-dance into work rise and shine
it's an espresso time what's up believe
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's
start your day off right to get there
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message love the game over to you Warren
Buffett also if you want to know what
Warren Buffett and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my to
54 confidence series where every day for
the next two hundred and fifty four days
I will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in a description below
it's important to associate with people
that are better than yourself the
allowance when I was a little boy was a
nickel a week but I liked the idea of
having a little more than the going to
work with then I went into business very
early
they started selling coca-cola
door-to-door I sold gotten door-to-door
or so Saturday folks Liberty magazine
Ladies Home Journal his name it said I
think I enjoyed the game almost right
from the start but I like being my own
boss that's one thing I liked about
delivering papers I got arranged the
route I wanted nobody was bothering me
at 5:00 or 6:00 in the morning
[Music]
I was delivering 500 papers a day and I
made a penny of paper but in terms of
compounding is that penny certain to
something else there isn't another
Warren Buffett because nobody loves a
specific game that he plays as much as
him you can study him model him read all
of his books and watch all of his videos
you can take the exact same path he took
doing everything exactly the same but
you'll never be Warren Buffett but the
goal should never be to be the next
Warren Buffett the goal should be what
can you learn from Warren Buffett to go
and crush the game that only you can
play now I'm a big fan of my land
success it's the name of my youtube
channel modeling success I've got tons
of people on my wall we've done books on
the topic I love the idea of modeling
success but at the end of the day I need
to do things in the way that only Evan
Carmichael can do look at how the whole
top ten series started as an example was
when a buddy of mine wrote a piece on
Kanye West attacking him for the whole
thing that happened Taylor Swift and
that bothered me because it was years
later and I just wanted people to take
the good from people I think we complain
too much I think we look at the negative
sides of people too much especially
people have had success they may be one
thing you don't like about them and so
you write them off where maybe there's a
hundred things you don't like about them
but there's one thing that you can learn
for me if there's one thing that I can
learn from someone who's accomplished
success I want to learn that to help me
be a better Evan Carmichael
so the first top ten that I did was on
Kanye West showing the good side of
Kanye showing how one of his friends
John Legend who how you have a hard time
imagining Kanye and John Legend being
friends John Legend's real name is John
Stevens and they met at a bar in Chicago
and he said he had a really old-school
voice and Kanye said you should call
yourself the legend and John Stevens was
like nah I can't call myself the legend
that's crazy what if I don't live up to
that expectation and Kanye convinced
himself to call himself the legend and
that's how he got the name John Legend
that's that's belief that's what I love
I love showing the positive things that
you can learn from people who've had a
lot of success Steve Jobs is a great
entrepreneur he's on my wall as well
Kanye is back there on the far corner
I love learning to be a visionary like
Steve Jobs I don't want to be a father
like him I take how to be a father from
my dad how to be a parent from my
parents who are also in the what was
appointing I think was pointing to
Howard chels I don't learn how to be
father like oats although I don't know
how good a good a father he is but I
learned how to be a parent from my
parents that's why they're up on the
wall and I think people lose when they
write people off if you are only willing
to learn from somebody who looks like
you who has the same upbringing or the
exact same belief system then you lose
you blocked yourself in Connie doesn't
worry if you want to learn from him or
not you've boxed yourself in by putting
him in the box you box yourself in and I
think that's a losing strategy and so
that's the goal with a lot of the
content that I put on my channel that's
the goal of the top ten series that even
if you hate this person I want you to
spend a few minutes trying to learn from
them because everything I put out is
positive everything I put out is belief
and the way that I do it is my process
is something that can't be copied people
say hey someone else is copying your
videos great let them copy the best are
gonna be as an Evan Carmichael jr. now
if you take my process and learn
something from it and then make your
business better to do something
different amazing I love it that's what
you should be doing and so I've won
because I do things my way in a way that
nobody else is doing it I've got my
mission I got my spin on it and that's
why my channels blowing up Warren
Buffett did the same thing he won
because he wins at his game he sets the
rules he figures it out he can play it
better than anybody else and so he wins
and so you need to figure out how to be
the best you what is the game that you
can crush that nobody else can crush
what are the unique combination of
things that you can bring together that
other people if they did it was a
strategy if other people copied you it's
a strategy or tactic but when you do it
from here you can't copy my belief you
can go do your own thing
you could try to copy but you're just
gonna be a copy you've got to find your
own thing and be willing to learn from
the people who you don't immediately
like respect or agree with because they
still have something to teach you so I'm
going to give you a three step process
to effective modeling how do you figure
out who the people are you should be
modeling and then break down there so
sass and apply it to your business step
number one is industry Mentors
this is the easiest place to start and
the place that you should start as
you're dipping your toes into the
modeling success pool so step one is
find people who've done it so when I
joined the software business that I was
an owner in and I was sucking and not
making any money I asked who has made a
lot of success happen in the software
business and Bill Gates was the guy that
came to mind
he started Microsoft and how he went
from zero to one is what I wanted to
model and I applied that strategy to my
business and within a couple weeks had a
thirteen and a half thousand dollar
check you know that may not seem like a
lot of money to you guys but for me when
I was making three hundred dollars a
month
thirteen and a half thousand dollars was
like hitting a lottery that was like
nothing we had tried worked at I felt
like I tried everything and then I tried
this one strategy from Bill Gates and I
had 13 1/2 thousand dollars in my bank
account that was crazy time and more
important than that I had a model that I
could use again and again and again and
again and again so find the people who
have done it in your industry now does
have to be exactly in the industry I was
selling biotech software Bill Gates
doesn't sell biotech sophomore but it
was close enough software is software
the model can be applied and so how
Microsoft went from zero to one I could
lean to my business too same thing for
your business whatever you're in start
by studying industry mentors except
number two is inspiring mentors just
people that you look up to if there's
somebody that you look up to that's had
success in a totally different field of
yours you can still learn from them and
apply it to your business and it's gonna
work because you respect them because if
Steve Jobs said one thing here's a
grater here's a better example if Donald
Trump says one thing and Barack Obama
says the same thing right they say the
exact same thing depending on who says
it you're gonna listen to one enough the
other whatever camp you're in I'm
Canadian so I didn't vote if you love
Chomp you'll listen to him and you'll
say Brock sucks and if you love rock
you'll listen to him and say Trump sucks
right and so when you look up the people
in a different industry that's had
success they have something to teach you
and you're more likely to listen because
you love that person because you believe
in what they've done because you respect
them and so think about who are the
three people that you love and look up
to that have nothing to do with your
business and then study their success
and see how they got started
you can learn from Ilan you can learn
from Oprah you can learn from Martha
Stewart you can learn from Issa Rae you
can learn from lots of different people
but the ones that will stick the
messages that will stick with you or the
ones that you care about the people that
you care about and so pick three
inspiring mentors go study their success
and then think Oprah did it this way but
I'm trying to sell shoes how can I learn
through Oprah and apply that to my
business and step number three the
hardest step is people you hate try to
study somebody who you hate who's had
success and maybe hates a strong word
you could be strongly disagree with if
you prefer fix someone who you strongly
disagree with and make a point to learn
from them make a point to see that they
have something that you can learn from
them that can apply to your situation
right now even if you strongly disagree
with 99.98% of everything that they
stand for because that actually becomes
a solution to get you out of your box
thinking when you are willing to learn
from Kanye if you strongly disagree with
Kanye you're gonna win when you decide
that you will learn from chump or Obama
even though you strongly disagree with
one of them whatever side of the fence
you're on when you decide that I will
learn from the person that I strongly
disagree with because they have
something to teach me then you start to
win then you start to actually grow that
really rapid fires your success curve
because you're willing to think and
learn from people outside the box now
got a really special bonus cut for you
that I think you're gonna enjoy before
that question of the day I want to know
who is somebody that you strongly
disagree with and still do strongly
disagree with most of what they say and
you've learned something from them I'd
love to know leave it in the comments
below
what are the qualities that you think
make for a true and a successful
entrepreneur what's important she or he
has to love the game for me a purebred
entrepreneur she or he loves the journey
mm-hmm
not the stuff you know one of the things
I struggle with in the current state of
entrepreneurship is a lot of people want
the vacations the watches you know even
even the context is this you guys have
such an incredible imagery I think it's
remarkable
who doesn't want fine things in life
yeah but I think that if you're in the
game just for the fine things in life
for the bottles and the models and the
private planes I think you're gonna lose
and it definitely is not my definition
of an entrepreneur my definition of an
entrepreneur is somebody who can't live
without doing their thing and trying to
create and I have this great luxury I
love my job I tap dance into work even I
get that I just got back for an amazing
vacation in Norway I got to go dog
sledding and go to a wolf preserve and
all this really cool stuff but I
couldn't wait to get back to work
because it's so fun and the reason
weather is this fun for me is I get to
work in the future so my job I'm I'm a
very limited kind of day-to-day
operational needs that you know I've
constructed my job so that I don't have
to be pulled into the present I can stay
2 or 3 years in the future if you want
more Warren Buffett check out the 10
mind-blowing facts about Warren Buffett
video made the link is right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there and
the only diploma I have in my office is
the Dale Carnegie
but the Dale Carnegie is up there
because that changed my life